how are you Wow not too bad okay that's
um what is on your head right now a
spider monkey spider monkey spider
monkey what is his name
mumble mumble I'm gonna meet him yes the
one thing you gotta know about primates
is like auditory things are very
Portman's like there's like that does
want me to do that yeah that's all
you're gonna meet him you were doing
that to attract me I've seen you at bus
stops okay okay so now you want to show
him your treat okay oh this is the treat
right here and this is a little gummy
something yeah no gummy think he loves
sweets a lot more no it's this is like
that he's seen this show before he's not
the other thing you should just look at
while you see him up here is he's got no
thumbs so he's not like a chimpanzee or
something that where he used their
opposable thumbs this guy does what they
call brachiating so you can you can see
sort of how his tail has wrapped around
each other's big long arms okay all that
stuff is for what they call breakage
that's swinging from branch to branch to
branch okay these guys never come down
that's regular he brought an animal on
that doesn't like sweets what's right
what you try to fruit then oh that a
word a bunch of little funny stuff okay
we'll try everything like this okay
obviously nothing no no okay that's not
working what else can we try
yeah he's just really not doing much
this is great television yep pretty much
12 the crowd the animals would attack
and this one's taking a little nappy pie
on your head I just leave this can I
leave this fruit in your hair I think
it's a good spot for
I'm just gonna now load your hair up
with gummy fish try making your noises
again do what Lady Gaga for the Grammys
me try Mickey come on buddy
giggle they know about your head cuz now
I'm depressed
no son come to a position I've ever been
in good anyone tuning in right now ok
well you know I don't want to I don't
want to frighten him he's beautiful he's
a spider monkey
you're just fighter monkey from Central
and South America ok well you see this
is doing what it would be doing in the
water it's like clinging on to mom or
dad saying hey this is new I want to
check it all out right and they feel
like there might be something different
than all that's a crazy environment view
you know it's insanity so let's move on
very nice red spider monkey I'm on mom's
next who's the next damn the next guy
I'm super excited about okay it is my
friend the sky the coyote pup you can
hold it I want to have it no you can't
have it these are I can't I have it
people think these are guys are good
good pets they're terrible pets because
what you want to do is support
supporters back you keep support those
back features and feel nervous that's it
like that perfect these guys are
actually taken in as pets a lot and
they're bad pets this is my Tiger Beat
photo spread I didn't realize I was
gonna bring all these animals for us to
rub our faces and heads up against
this is the same kind of coyote that you
would see all around here in California
the types of the guys that are sort of
in the wild spaces up here now this is
you know I really connect with this
coyote if I raise this coyote would it
eventually do my bidding you know do
your bidding you know the problem with
it is is these guys are somewhat
solitary mostly solitary so they're not
used to like being a pack like a dog or
a wolf so the bond wouldn't be as tight
as it would be if you raised it they
raised a wolf he got many became an
adult he'd be dangerous to me you know
he'd be skittish and if you scared him
he'd bite no it's funny these guys have
got a real bad rap around California
because we do we do go after like the
small dogs and I don't know what I'm
doing right now I don't know what you're
doing right now I'm just looking him
yeah well if you know it's mom or dad
would be looking inside this it's my
wife does she's like uh uh no we go you
better take it he's beautiful I love
that guy and I will raise him I want to
raise him here in California all right
should we try out the [ __ ] the next one
yeah sure
you